ladies and gentlemen we have a great
show tonight
[Applause]
Oh
have a seat have a seat that is
this fan right here just keeps shooting
you with a Ghostbusters ray I don't know
how that's supposed to make you feel
good I don't understand any of it Peter
Capaldi thank you so much for being here
and entering with such a terrible
special effect
I'm you stood I travel with my own
dry-ice this yeah very nice I guess like
some fog and clearly ropes pulling
pulling you in is this am I correct
this is your first comic-con is that
right my very first Comic Con Wow tell
us about it how is it what's your
experience been like
well everyone kept saying to me are you
nervous oh you nervous making me more
nervous right as the day of the panel
approached and we were in there the
hotel for two days doing press and the
security people kept saying you can't go
out onto the street you can't go out
there because you'll get mobbed and I
was like come on guys put yourself in my
shoes you know I play this iconic
character wouldn't you walk down the
street yeah just like that kind Oh
exactly what you want to own it you're
Doctor Who get out there so you walk
down the street and like nobody comes
one little kid comes up and then
gradually another person comes in
another person comes and before I know
it I'm done Utley a convention center
yeah at the lion you know and there were
so many our wonderful people
I felt I felt like running for office up
the woods yeah you know what's
interesting is you grew up a Doctor Who
fan the show has been on for you know 50
years you grew up a Doctor Who fan now
you are playing Doctor Who sometimes on
the set you have to feel like it's a
dream almost a childhood dream oh it's
absolutely incredible as a child you
know I I wrote to Doctor Who I got
letters back from the original Doctor
Who's you know I I drew pictures and
sent them to the BBC I got a letter
published in the equivalent of TV Guide
thank how much what is really
embarrassing though is that now they dig
up all this stuff and you know if you
you don't really want to hear what your
14-year old self has to say yeah about
things but especially if they don't
explain you wrote it as a 14-year old so
I just Peter Capaldi said me like Doctor
Who you know it's interesting different
actors take a different approach to
Doctor Who some people think that your
take has been to be a little more grumpy
yeah fair to say yeah well he's two and
a half thousand years old he's been
around yeah and life is tough business
as usual yeah but he loves the great
thing about Doctor Who I think he's that
is he's actually full of joy because he
loves time and space and the universe
you know he can find beauty in the
simplest of things he can sit in the
supermarket carpark you know and watch
the Sun coming up and think that's the
most amazing thing or see stars being
born in Alpha Centauri he's made it's
incredible